in addition to being an astonishingly
popular piece of advice
follow your passion is also an
astonishingly bad piece of advice be so
good they can't ignore you if you do
that lots of other good things will come
this is why I think our productivity
metrics have been stagnant for over a
decade is even though the tech has
gotten more advanced we have fragment
that our attention to the degree that
we're actually really bad at the core
thing that we need to do digital
minimalism is a philosophy of technology
use
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one study success you should look to
let's say professional musicians
professional athletes professional chess
players people who have to get good in a
world that has a well-defined competence
hierarchy where you have a chess ranking
and you can't run away from it you have
a batting average right you know like
you can't you can't get away from it
watch how they train because in their
world there's a lot of effort that has
gone into how do you systematically
improve and what you see is that they
deliberately practice and there's really
no shortcut to deliberate practice to
gaining mastery in almost any field but
in knowledge work in particular so in
this sort of whole array of sort of
various creative and other types of
professions we don't think that way and
people don't actually do a lot of this
sort of systematic practice and so
that's why in so good they can't ignore
you I go and I hang hang out with
professional guitar player and I say
okay I want to watch you practice and in
this case there's actually a good reason
to do so because this is someone who
started playing guitar at the same time
that I started playing guitar and at the
age where like I was not that great I
played in a rock band and we were like
okay he was being he had a record deal
is being heralded as like this talent
right in a new acoustic guitar playing
so he said great I want to understand
why did he become really really good and
I did it
watching him practice in this sort of
musicians frat house he lived in in
Boston with all these other musicians
answer the question hundred percent
he was so intense when he was practicing
the guitar that he would forget to
breathe right so he'd be doing this he
was trying to get a lick faster so the
way he got the lick faster is let me
play it about ten percent faster than I
can comfortably play it he was so
concentrated he'd forget to breathe and
so he would do these ragged gasps every
once in a while when his body would
force something taken it take an air
that's the whole difference I never did
that that's stretching you're like what
I need to do is be better at this lick
and so I'm going to push myself beyond
or uncomfortable also if you want to
have more confidence check in my 254
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below I was reminded
this morning of a question I'm often
asked how do you eliminate fear from
your life if you're doing work that you
loved you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it in a
sess world please understand that
success is happiness not net dollars in
rule number two get rid of social media
digital minimalism is a philosophy of
technology use and it says what you
should do is wipe the slate clean of the
various apps and services that you have
haphazardly downloaded or just started
using at various parts in your digital
life and instead rebuild it from scratch
but very intentionally so that the tools
that you actually use your digital life
directly serve things that you very care
about when it comes to social media I
think you have to understand what's
actually happening with this product
which is this is an experience that has
evolved over time from what it used to
be which was a relatively static way for
you to post information about yourself
and see information for people you care
about it's shifted from that into an
experience in which they are sending a
stream of social approval indicator
about yourself at you all day long
likes and retweets and tags of photos
that are constantly coming at you
deliver through this app and that every
time you hit this button you might see
some new indication that someone else
was thinking about you that type of
behavior that experience is something
that was not innovated because it made
users happier this is an experience that
has been engineered to make you a
compulsive user of your phone and
therefore should be something that makes
you wary rule number three don't just
follow your passion American culture is
obsessed with this idea that the only
way to end up happy in what you do for a
living is to follow your passion you'd
be hard-pressed to find a career guide
book a career counsellor or a career
advice blogger whose whole philosophy
somewhere deep down is not based on this
idea but there's also a problem here so
the more I researched into this issue
the more I became convinced that in
addition to being an astonishingly
popular piece of advice follow your
passion is also an astonishingly bad
piece of advice
I want to be clear about what I mean by
that in science just let me in science
it's very hard to get things named after
you so I really overcompensate when it
comes to my writing there's nothing
that's not too much but what I'm saying
here is that I have nothing against the
goal of Indiana passionate about what
you do in fact that's what this whole
talk is about how do people actually get
there what I'm arguing however is that
the specific strategy of identifying a
pre-existing passion then following it
is a bad strategy for achieving that
goal there's a couple of reasons I
believe this first follow your passion
presupposes that you have a pre-existing
passion that you can identify and follow
we actually don't have a lot of evidence
that this is true for most people in
fact one study I wrote about it had a
psychologist take a large group of
seniors this is at a Canadian university
a large group of seniors and they
subjected them to all of these
questionnaires to try to figure out what
if anything they were passionate about
and I went back and went through the
data and even being very generous in my
accounting it was less than 5% of these
students that actually had a passion
that was even remotely relevant to a
career choice probably guess the number
one passion whose Canadian University
was hockey the second problem is that
follow your passion presupposes that if
you really like something and then match
that to your job you will then from then
on out have a sort of long-term engaging
and meaningful career and this turns out
to be an incredibly simplistic and
reductive understanding of workplace
satisfaction and what's involved in
actually building a long term career
that provides both meaning and
engagement if you want this emphasized
look no farther than all the examples of
passionate amateur photographers or
passionate amateur bakers that end up
miserable and overworked
when they open their own photography
studio or their own bakery this tells us
that something more is going on
here but I think actually the most
ironic let's say the most ironic example
of the insufficiency of this advice is
actually Steve Jobs himself so even
though Steve Jobs stood on that stage in
2005 and said what people at least
interpreted to mean
follow your passion his biographers make
it clear that that's not at all what he
did right his biographers tell us that
in the period leading up the Apple
Computer Steve Jobs did not have an
unusual passion for technology
entrepreneurship Apple was something
that he stumbled into one of his
biographers put it this way Apple is a
small-time scheme that unexpectedly took
off but of course no one doubts that
Steve Jobs ended up quite passionate
about what he did for a living which
tells us the lesson here is it's not how
you get started that matters maybe what
matters is what you do once you get
going rule number four be so good they
can't ignore you be so good they can't
ignore you it's like that's what Martin
used to tell aspiring entertainers and
what he said was well they always were
hoping there's gonna be some secret or
here's how you get noticed or here's how
you get the right age and what he would
always tell them is be so good they
can't ignore you if you do that lots of
other good things will come and so I
ended up naming that book so good they
can't ignore you is because that advice
basically turns out to be incredibly
applicable especially if you're new
let's say you're new to the job market
you're right out of school you want to
be passionate about what you do by far
probably the most important thing you
can do the most important step you can
take if you want to maximize the
probability that you have a fantastic
working life just put your head down and
go into apprentice mode I'm gonna master
something that's unambiguously valuable
you do that on that foundation all sorts
of really good things come good things
that include real satisfaction and
passion for your work rule number five
live intentionally I think something
that's going on here and I think foods a
good analogy right so in food we're used
to this idea that you might say
something like I don't eat this type of
food I don't think it's I don't think
it's good for me right I mean obviously
this is a message you've taught
everything a lot about and no one comes
back and says you know well rich role is
a sort of anti food guy he's not in the
eating there's nothing attrition right
where you
- and the idea of food that there's
there's different qualities and get
different results out of it and so I'm a
tech guy I mean I'm a computer scientist
I'm an internet nerd I was using the net
before you know there was worldwide web
browsers I've been blogging for over a
decade and so I look at certain things
like social media platforms and to me
it's junk food and so I don't see it as
a stance of you know neo-luddism to say
for example I don't use Facebook I see
it more like saying I don't eat Doritos
mm-hmm and that you can you can love
tech like I do but not necessarily
embrace all of the trends and so that's
a lot of the message I'm out there out
there preaching is that you have to be
intentional you have to be selective
rule number six have an insane work
ethic so this is the environmental
writer the celebrated environmental
writer Bill McKibben now Bill McKibben
is someone who loves what he does for a
living okay he is a celebrated author he
writes books full time maybe one every
two or three years their big idea books
their books on topics that he's
interested in he lives in the sort of a
Dilek town in Vermont and he has a life
by all accounts that he's very
passionate about so let's use him as our
case study let's ask the question how
did Bill McKibben end up with a working
life that he loved now I would
conjecture that the short answer to that
question is skill if we dive into the
details of Bill McKibben's life we see
the turning point for him happened with
the publication of his first book in the
late 1980s this was a book called the
end of nature and it was quickly
heralded as a new classic in the field
of environmental books the most
important environmental book since
Rachel Carson's Silent Spring and
immediately made him a celebrity author
at least within this field that allowed
him to quit his magazine job and quit
the freelance assignments he moved first
to the Adirondacks and then to this
small town in Vermont and it allowed him
to kick off this life of just writing
about what interests to him have an
impact on the world and really enjoying
his life but if we ask well how did he
write the end of nature the important
thing to keep in mind is by the time he
actually got the book deal for that book
he had become one of the most talented
environmental writers
his generation he was a staff writer for
The New Yorker who specialized in these
issues he had a big book deal from
Random House to go write this book to
New York or serialized the book while he
was writing it so was definitely going
to be seen it was definitely gonna make
an impact the fact that he was such a
talented writer by this point is what
made him capable of transforming his
life in this way that generated a lot of
passion for him now there's a question
we have to ask you how did he end up
becoming one of the most talented
environmental writers of his generation
and I want to conjecture here that he
was not born a brilliant or naturally
talented writer and I'll use this as my
exhibit a this comes from as far as I
can tell in my research the first
published work of a young Bill McKibben
he published this in the Harvard Crimson
soon after arriving as an undergraduate
at Harvard University it was a sports
page article about the Celtics opening
day game so it doesn't take a Pulitzer
committee to tell you that this is not
good writing okay it's all the classic
mistakes of a very young new writer is
completely overblown way too effusive
and of course a completely inappropriate
tone for an article where people want to
know whether Larry Bird was feeling
healthy or not which was the concern in
1979 but the point is if you talked to
crimson staffers today and this is what
it's important to know about Bill
McKibben they still talk about is lore
at the Crimson his work ethic he wrote
an absurd number of articles while there
there's this tale that that they tell
about it was like a late cambridge city
council meeting they came back he had an
hour until deadline and he bet the
fellow editors you know a bottle of
scotch and i'll get these two articles
written and in before the deadline then
he won that bottle of scotch because
that's the type of work ethic he had he
wrote an absurd number of articles in
through sheer brute practice became a
better and better writer and by the time
he graduated Harvard he was the editor
of the Crimson that put him on the radar
a bill Shon at the New Yorker who hired
him to edit the short talk of the town
pieces in the front of the magazine
he worked at that really hard they let
him start a Qui
longer pieces eventually became staff
writer he could specialize in the
environment then the end of nature
happened and he was able to transform
his life into this one that he's very
passionate about rule number seven do
your research well I don't think we we
think enough about how hard it is to
actually do interesting and successful
things and so this is a real issue that
I got into in that original book where
young people in particular would write
their own script for this is how I want
the world to work this is how you know I
want to run this thing and I want it to
be really successful and I want X Y & Z
and here's what I want to be important
for this that I'm on social media law
it's gonna be key and the fact that I'm
just a young go-getter and this will all
work out in about a year
but like the reality is everything that
is worthwhile is really really hard and
it's often really really specific and so
I'm always telling young people
something very similar before you make
your plan for how you're going to
execute you know becoming a book author
for example which a lot of people ask me
about go talk to authors figure it out
figure out what the actual reality is of
what matters and how people succeed
don't write your own script that with
the answers that you want it to be
because often there's a real conflict
it's easy to come up with some plan
where you're like I'm gonna do X Y & Z
I'm gonna write 20 pages a day and
something that's kind of hard but not
too hard and you think it's going to be
fun and it might have nothing to do with
how that industry works but on the other
hand if you can get the intelligence
maybe by by interning with someone who
can actually teach you about the field
you really care about and you understand
this is what's involved then you know
where to put your energy rule number
eight explore let's say you had a time
machine and you could go back to meet a
young Steve Jobs I probably the first
thing you would do is go buy Apple stock
but let's say you go back even earlier
than that in a high school age Steve
Jobs the biographical sources we have
today suggest that if you talk to a
young Steve Jobs you would not come away
with the idea that he was passionate
about building a technology company did
not have at that point in his life a
passion for changing the world through
technology right so Steve Jobs did not
go to Berkeley to study Electrical
Engineering which is what she would have
done in that time in that place if you
were really passionate about electronics
and he didn't go to Stanford or UCLA to
study business which is probably what
you would have done in that time in that
place
if you're very passionate
entrepreneurship and business he instead
went to Reed College a liberal arts
school up in Oregon you studied history
study dance pretty soon afterwards he
dropped out and hung out on campus
walking around barefoot experimenting
with sort of extreme diets bumming free
meals from the Hare Krishna temple
eventually he got fed up with being
completely destitute came back to
California took a night shift job at
Atari and that was very specific because
he wanted flexibility and not too much
responsibility and he began the study
Eastern mysticism way more seriously
that it just arrived on the shores of
the west coast in this period he went on
a min deqin journey to India in this
point months-long min the kins journey
to India came back started to study
seriously at the Los Altos end center
and began to spend an increasing amount
of time with the all one communist state
so the point of this is that this is a
portrait of someone who is seeking did
the classic example of someone young
early in their life trying to figure out
what life's about what they want to do
with their life a lot of us go through
this stage but jobs being jobs couldn't
just read Kerouac he had to actually go
to India and spent three months because
he's intense about everything he does
but he's basically reflecting something
that a lot of us went through ourselves
trying to understand what what are we
doing here what's the meaning of life he
was in a seeking mode but what's clear
about that is this was certainly not
someone with a crystal clear vision of I
am passionate about starting a
technology company and I'm gonna find a
way to do that one way or the other rule
number nine be truly productive so the
problem was with email and slack and
this was really at the core of my last
book so not digital minimalism but but
deep work right what was this notion
that as the knowledge economy in
particular so let's just look at
knowledge work and as you get past the
entry level knowledge work is really
built on concentration because what you
have to do literally speaking is taking
information think about it produce new
information that has value right I mean
that's the that's the gristmill of
knowledge work so you introduce
something like email and it seems like a
no-brainer like we we write memos it
takes a long time if we can do it
electronically just has massive
advantages it's cheaper it's faster it's
more stable I can access it when I'm
away from the mail we don't need a whole
mailroom
it just seems like there's all these
advantages to it but there's unexpected
consequences and in particular what
happened is once we introduced things
like email it shifted the way we worked
and so subtly our workflow shifted to
something that I call the hyperactive
hivemind which is let's have a
constantly ongoing unstructured
conversation so this have a lot of
knowledge work now unfolds you can use
slack or email or whatever tool SMS is
now integrating the office a lot more
where we can just anyone can reach
anyone at any time so it's like we have
this ongoing unstructured conversation
which wasn't possible before but this
technology makes possible its it's not
an unnatural thing to do it's basically
how you know we would coordinate if we
were in like a small group of peel with
ik hunters we would just sort of have an
unstructured conversation you go that
way I'll go this way
we just scaled it up the large
organizations by using these tools the
problem is if you have to tend this
ongoing unstructured conversation it
forces you to have to keep changing your
attention back to the communication
tools and then back to the thing that
you're actually trying to produce value
on then back to the communication tools
you have the context switch a lot and
the psychology literature tells us that
that context switching just completely
reduces our cognitive capacity makes it
very difficult for us to actually
concentrate and produce value with our
brain so it was an inadvertent
externality but by introducing these
low-friction communication tools it
changed the way we work to make things
much more convenient but by doing that
we actually got much worse at the core
business of knowledge work which
requires conversation producing value
and so this is why I think our
productivity metrics have been stagnant
for over a decade is even though the
tech has gotten more advanced we have
fragment that our attention to the
degree that we're actually really bad at
the core thing that we need to do which
is actually sitting there and writing
the legal brief and rule number 10 the
last 20 for a very special bonus clip is
use time blocking let's say you buy this
notion that the systematic development
of rare and valuable skills is key to a
working life you love how do you
actually do that say today let's say in
a creative or knowledge work type field
so I think the evidence suggests that
this type of work plays a crucial role
but we have decades of research from
performance psychology as well as
neuroscience that tells us that this
state of cognitive strain where you
persist even though it's uncomfortable
is exactly a state in which you improve
at a cognitive skill so the heuristic is
simple if you want to be cultivating a
rare and valuable skill in a knowledge
worker create a pursuit a non-trivial
fraction of your work hours have to be
dedicated to this type of work but we
know what this is right instead of being
reactive about your day you plan out in
advance that's what I'm gonna do here
that's what I'm gonna do there this is a
sample time block document from my
notebook as you can see I block my hours
on the left on the right i elaborate
we're needed on the immediate right I
leave myself extra space so that I can
repair the schedule as it gets disrupted
during the day it's simple now of course
time blocking has lots of sort of
general productivity benefits it forces
you to make critical decisions about
your time I think more importantly it
forces you to come to grips with how
long things actually take which turns
out to play a crucial role in scheduling
but when it comes to deep work in
particular it's absolutely necessary
deep work is not a natural activity it's
not something that you're going to do
spontaneously if you're not planning in
advance what you do win it's not going
to show up in your schedule so this is
sort of the foundation on which deep
work makes its way into knowledge work
working schedules now I have a special
bonus clip from Cowell on how to lower
the bar that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one how will
you use time Block in to fix your
schedule number two what does an
intentional life look like for you and
number three where do you need to be so
good that they can't ignore you and if
you liked this video and will take
action after watching it give me a
hashtag believe down in the comments as
well so we have to lower the bar from
this impossible height where we put it
which is you have a one true passion and
if you figure it out you're gonna love
your work starting the next day and if
you get it wrong you're destined for a
life of misery like we have to lower
that bar down to there are many
different things upon which you could
build a life of
fulfillment and passion but it's not
just dark throwing right I mean it has
to be something that you have an
interest in it has to be something that
you think would reward you with more
flexibility and options as you got
better at it right so so it's not just
arbitrary but most people could probably
pretty quickly identify six or seven
directions that pass those qualifiers
and so a lot of what I'm saying is
that's enough that's enough for the past
a bar I like this maybe it matches some
of my skills I like the options of it
open up if I did it well it seems to
resonate in some sort of ill-defined or
ambiguous way that's all enough for
something to be the foundation of a
passionate career and there's probably a
lot of things that that pass that
criterion that's okay
if you want to know the three amazing
habits that the 1% use every day check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there other than the five-second rule
there is one habit that I have adopted
in the last three years